I didn't have any green eyes bloody nose
our town has been the one that has had
multiple experiences with major rashes
all over her body some days her legs are
covered with big red rashes some days
four stomachs covered with big red
rashes oh go away few hours later and
then astronaut will come close to Porter
Ranch here we are again starting all
over
we first know the gas leak on October
23rd on October 24th we call the gas
company in your best times and they said
there's normal venting call the gas
company is that I heard that there's no
leak at your facility is there and they
said no sir there's no leak everything's
fine it's normal maintenance like oh the
fire department told me there's a leak
no sir there's no leak bunch and lying
motherfuckers
no treatment except for leave the area
that's what they said if this persists
just get out of the area